okay so
e4 the opening went very well in the
first game
so it makes perfect sense to to repeat
even if magnus he likes to change to
test a bit
but uh i don't know maybe he has a
dinner in pamplona
so he has no time to to
to share with us so he has a limited
amount of
amount of time to to share with us
i don't know queen a5 played fast by
eduardo
now c3 i guess is um logical move
but c3 knight c6 would lose a pawn
actually
takes takes takes so c3
um and it's already
some not so easy so maybe b5 first
bishop c2
and knight c6 okay
because takes just helps white you can
takes like that and then you go d4 md5
look i mean
something like that it's just incredibly
bad for black
so you have to do something to protect
your opponent differ
vamos eduardo make it
exciting
a little bit at least b5
bishop c2 will come reasonably fast
i think yeah bishop c2 and knight c6
this is typical he wants b4 a4 okay
that's interesting of course
a4 will come a tempo now you cannot
keep this pawn b5 because if a6 takes
takes
and eurozok that's not good
so you take here but here you you gave
away your pawn structure
now now this is bad and also you gave
away this knight on
the square on c4 for the night this is
very important that could be a
very important tempo on the queen
so bishop is seven
now knight a3 looks like the only
square for the knight so and it looks
like like a good one because knight c4
will come
okay castle
knight c4 maybe b5 and
um i don't know maybe bishop b2 as well
is a move
just to force black to force a decision
here e5 well
that's a move apparently according to
the to the bar
evaluation bar which you can see on the
left
of your screen and on my right
you have this evaluation bar and it's
spotted the
tactics takes b4
the knight is hanging on c4
so that's a good tactic
and that's uh tactic magnus
seems that it'd be missed it he wanted
to play b5
maybe bishop a3 knight d6 thought there
is no
no contact in the air but knight b4 is a
it's a nice one
so again he's in trouble already because
he's just a pawn
if you go knight d6 i will just go
knight d3 i guess i take c5 and
this knight is hanging this is not good
if you take here
i just take here and i'm a pawn up and
your pawn is weak
and you play knight d6 but there is
knight d3 and
it was a guy will see it of course
now you will see knight takes e5 that's
for sure
i mean if you spot knight takes before
your spot knight take e5 i mean this
is no no way and i take e5
if you take on c8 i just take with of
the hooks maybe that one just to
to get this you take here it's just a
pawn i mean uh
and here there is like this or even
okay so he's thinking to make sure
because when you get a free pawn like
that
and the world champion you just you have
troubles to
to believe it could be hcd
and just knight g6 i guess knight d3
yeah
ag6 is very good bishop b7 will come a6
bishop c6
such just pawn down and better position
for black
he has two he has to do something d5
bishop b7 and now
now we will see the most difficult part
because the is the easiest part on
getting a winning position it's not easy
but it's easier than
winning it so he won
d4 now you play by hand just to to to
open up
as a bishop it looks so winning for
black bishop c6 oh okay
this is already in the wrong direction
you have to play d4 come on yeah bishop
d6 attack here
wow such such a bad position
okay queen h5 to protect that pawn to
create some kind of
then i cannot move from g6 rook e8
makes a lot of sense you want to mate
after takes takes you are tightening
mate here bishop b2 you go
d4 you go b8
just a table position 28 played if you
go bishop a3 i just take if you take
it's mate in one so you can't do that
you have a it's really it looks so very
it's a very simple thread but it's very
difficult to to
stop it i think for that one to be
very very difficult for magnus to escape
i would be very surprised
but i've been surprised so many times
by the gate magnus bishop b5
attacking here
d3 what else ca this is very well played
and he has a he has a lot of time i mean
58 seconds it's a lot of time
uh knight f4 not really india because
bishop
will take okay to what's
uh he's hanging in there but
that's not great let's face it maybe
maybe something like bishop a4 could be
funny
if bishop a4 rook c1
knight c1 queen one mate
if you go okay four i go off c2 this
looks completely winning to me bishop a4
in the spirit of the background mate
okay between e5 okay
offering a queen trade this ending is of
course completely winning
but magma is still in the game i mean
two points but and now it will make a
small square i don't know g3 knight d4
yeah j3 played no knight f4
you just stop this this knight from
jumping
in attract attractive squares
97 is a good move reloading the knight
9786 okay it's less winning than b4 but
it's still completely winning 30 seconds
okay bishop f6 if magnus survives that
this is just
and bishop d4 and already some questions
i would take and play knight c6
that looks good to me
good and simple 96 immediately okay
okay so spoiling the pawns
but i think knight b4 he can play knight
b4 anyway
okay d4 king f2 and now
now he'll go g4 i know him at some point
here we go g4 knight g5 is a good move
okay knight g1 knight f3 rebooting the
knight but of course it's still
completely
hopeless but it's a blitz king of six
oh he's really scared about any kind of
jumps
something that's easy for ooh that was
missed
that was missed as well i think by both
me
and eduardo the position is so winning
that he's still winning
okay but already you can see that he can
save it maybe okay so the engine is
showing
that's it's equal already this is just
insane
and now you will take on x2 i guess
check
first come on you have to play on
eduardo
eduardo play
now come on you can't make it over here
he's fighting he's just oh no come on
oh come on you have to you have to play
here oh if magnus plays on then
no no no it was his chance i mean like
i don't know you just play you take h2
and you see